وزير الخارجيه التركي الجديد هاكان فدان
تخرج من المدرسه الحربيه للقوات البريه
واكمل تعليمه الجامعيه اثناء خدمته في
الجيش التركي توجه للحياه الاكاديميه في
عدد من الجامعات بعد خدمته في الجيش تولى
مناصب مهمه في مجالات السياسه الخارجيه
والامن على مستويات حكوميه مختلفه كان
مسؤولا عن سياسه الخارجيه وقضايا الامن في
رئاسه الوزراء شغل منصب نائب رئيس جهاز
الاستخبارات التركيه في ابريل من عام 2010
في الشهر التالي تولى رئاسه جهاز
الاستخبارات لثلاثه عشر عاما حتى تم
تكليفه بحقيبه وزاره الخارجيه
هاكان فيدان هو صندوق اسراري وصف اطلقه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على فيدان
قبل اعوام
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات